there's so much we didn't know about
this place Henry world upon world entire
civilizations far more than we ever
theorized it's okay
[Music]
passing through we stake no claim
there
it's better be good as mine
we checked every security camera in the
area they all had ants on ants no ants
in this one though exterminator sprayed
the store two days ago
what is that well that my friend is how
I'm staying in the picture now the tech
in that labs got to be worth billions
find them and whose mom I wanna know who
that is right hey everybody its charlie
we got new deleted scenes to break down
foreshadowing some big stuff during
Avengers 4 so we got to talk about
quantum realm multiple realities the
multiverse as well as a new basis for
the x-gene and x-men mutants within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so there's a
new round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this the first big thing is Janet
Van Dyne talking all about whole
civilizations worlds upon worlds that
she's learned about in the quantum realm
those are references to a couple big
things one she's talking about the
quantum city that's in the background
when Scott goes down into the quantum
realm it's really small in the
background you can barely see it if we
get a third a man in the wasp film maybe
they'll pay it off then the tardigrades
that she talks to in this clip that are
their own subgroup of apparently
intelligent life-forms that live down
there the quantum city is more about the
micro not so it's not like the bunch of
tardigrades live in the quantum city
down there it's more of a reference to
Micronauts the Microverse which is the
MCU version of the quantum realm more
humanoid looking people that you could
actually interact with in a more
realistic way I did a video before the
movie came out explaining how the
Microverse and the micronauts are owned
by another toy company so when Marvel
did the first ant-man movie and he went
down in there they had to change the
name to quantum realm but the second big
thing that Janet Van Dyne is referencing
when she's talking about these new
things that she's learned about the
quantum realm is other worlds as in
different earths of different realities
because of the way the quantum realm
connects to the multiverse so the way
the ghost character works during the
movie is a pretty good example of why
quantum energy is the key to traveling
the multiverse because she gets
bombarded with just regular quantum
energy during an accident that leaves
her body in an unstable quantum state
constantly shifting between realities
each time tearing her molecules apart
and then stitching them back together so
with just regular quantum energy like
Scott Lang is :
ding during the post credit scene is the
key to shifting travelling between
different realities the desert of
backdoor confirms that there's one
quantum realm amongst the entire
multiverse like it's the common
denominator that connects all the
different realities one quantum realm
infinite universes we've seen all those
pictures that the Avengers walking
around with similar risk devices during
Avengers 4 with ant-man implying that
he's a key part of whatever it is that
they're doing there we've gotten teasers
that we're gonna find out what dr.
Strange's won in 14 million timeline was
that they ultimately defeated Thanos for
good winning the war despite losing the
battle at the end of infinity war like
sacrificing your pawns in a big chess
game so they ultimately win the match a
couple of big ideas that everybody has
about how the Avengers learn how they
defeat Thanos and one is time travel and
2 is viewing other realities of the
multiverse but the interesting thing
about time travel is is that back during
2011 I actually forgot China outright
banned films that are based on time
travel think back to the future style
time travel where you go back and you
mess with the past or you take something
from the future or gain some knowledge
they didn't specify whether these were
films that were based on time traveling
in real history like changing real world
events or it was fake history because
technically the MCU is fake so why would
it be such a big deal if they go back in
time or go forward in time and change
things so that is why I'm starting to
lean closer to the be ar effing way that
they view the past so while it might
look like they're just time-traveling
here this might actually be B AR effing
technology like the Russos initially
said people thought that they were lying
when they said that but because Marvel
isn't gonna release a movie is expensive
as the Avengers 4 was to make they can't
be released in China because of some
silly thing like time-travel they're
gonna find a way around that and the VAR
effing way of time traveling without
quote unquote time-traveling like it's
not them physically travelling back in
time it's just them looking at their
memories from the past that could be
what's going on here magic is also
banned in China in movies but travelling
between universes and the multiverse
that's not magic so that would still be
fair game the other really important
idea about Janet Van Dyne in the quantum
realm
during the movie is the idea that it
changed her you could say quote-unquote
mutated her body like she says that
she's different she's a changed person
and she uses quantum energy to heal the
ghost towards the end of the film all
this quantum realm quantum energy just
provides another inroad into
biologically powered people in the MCU
ahead of them just straight-up pudding
x-men in movies in the next couple of
years so the really cool thing you may
have spotted is is that recently an MCU
book about the movies describes Scarlet
Witch is a straight-up metahuman not
somebody that had artificial powers
saying that the mind gem only unlocked
something that was already within her
meaning that MCU Scarlet Witch already
had the biological potential for power
the mind gem just sort of flipped on the
x-gene quote-unquote but obviously they
couldn't have done that before the x-men
deal went through that's probably one of
the reasons why you haven't heard them
really examine Wanda's powers in great
detail the way that Iron Man talks about
the way he powers his energy suits or
them talking about quantum energy one of
the best quotes in the movie do you just
put the name quantum in front of
everything the Sonny Burch clip really
just gets into PIMs quantum Tech and him
wanting to sell it to the quote unquote
group of buyers that have billions of
dollars and don't take no for an answer
I've already done a video about that
because there's all this stuff swirling
in the background with sinister six in
the spider-man trilogy of movies I still
think it's a trilogy even though
technically they only have two on their
contract
spider-man far from home is the last
movie that Marvel has on that Sony
sharing arrangement so they have to
resize a new deal if they're gonna do a
third film with Marvel but it just seems
like based on the types of things that
we've been getting there was a new scene
that just dropped I'll talk about in a
second to where we're building towards
sinister six in Norman Osborn inside the
MCU it's just gonna take a little while
to get there and depends on what Sony
does in the next couple of years with
that Marvel sharing a range but if they
sign a new one so if you guys didn't see
recently really awesome there was a clip
of Mysterio that just drops so I'll do a
video for that tomorrow so spider-man
far from home Mysterio confirm Jake
Gyllenhaal we all wondered whether it
was in the movie people said that he was
on set but apparently now it's pretty
much confirmed so I'll do a video for
that because there's also been a lot of
theories about what's going on with that
movie but that's completely separate
from what's going on with this stuff so
that video should be up in the
morning on Monday nightmare Freddy
Krueger congratulations you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here for that new spider-man far from
home black costume video and click here
for that new venom trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight
[Music]
you